♪ ("BLUSH"
BY SIENA LIGGINS PLAYS) ♪
A guy asked me to call him
"Daddy" in bed recently.
And it was Father's Day,
so I was like, "Okay,
I'll give it to ya."
I found the best way
to discourage something in bed
that you're not into is...
So I gave in, at first.
It was hard, but I was like...
And by the end of it,
I was just like...
He came right away.
I am tired of
you girls in your 20s
dating men my age...
According to all
my 40-year-old friends,
there's an...
Of course you like
the only thing old about a woman
that you can't see.
You never hear a guy going,
"She's 23.
I know she's 23, Nikki,
but seriously, she's got,
like, the oldest pussy."
I'm 37. All I do is talk
about my vagina on stage.
It's like, "Enough!"
I'm just at this point in
my career where I'm ready to...
close that chapter
and pivot, like...
Like, you guys,
I have not even begun.